and I'm not talking into the mic or good
morning John it's Tuesday that sound
better obviously you and I talk a lot
about nonprofit organizations and like
doing good part of doing good is
realizing that there's something bad
something wrong with the world and I
recently got a YouTube message from a
nerdfighter and this message got to
maybe realized something that I kind of
mostly react in one of two ways to all
the world's major and minor tragedies
either I feel bad because of the tragedy
or I feel bad for not feeling bad
because of the tragedy and John I just
don't think that that attitude is going
to be good for anyone least of all me
and frankly I am the most important
person ok you think that I was kidding
about that but I'm not I've spent my
entire life viewing the entire world
from only one point of view the point of
view of me so how might not be the most
important person I over value myself we
all over value ourselves that's part of
life but that's not the point I was
trying to make in this video what was
the point I was trying to make in this
video oh yeah like when a friend of a
friend dies in some bizarre freaky
pyrotechnical accident it feels like we
have an obligation to care about those
things but if you don't think a lot
about this kind of stuff and I imagine
most of us don't think a lot about this
kind of stuff because it's not the most
pleasant stuff to think about we end up
thinking that there's only one way to
care and that way is the way that we
care about our wives and our cats and
our kids and our dads so that is not the
only kind of caring and we can't have
that kind of caring for everyone in the
world if I cared about all the cats in
the world the way I care about my cat I
would never leave my bed
due to the crushing weight to the
responsibility of all of these sad
impoverished lonesome cats and they
start crying right now
because I'm thinking about all of the
cats the way I think about my cat I'm
going to now make funny faces because I
was talking too much about sad cats oh
that's better
so there's that first kind of caring the
wise and cats and dads and kids kind of
caring but there is also another kind of
caring that is extremely important that
we cannot ignore that is not love it's
not that irrational emotional visceral
soul-crushing soul lifting warmth
embracing kind of feeling that we have
for the people that we really care about
but there's also another very important
kind of caring and for a lack of a
better word I'm going to call it
compassion that we can have for all the
cats in the people and the Y's and the
kids and the dads of all the people in
the world without the soul-crushing way
of love the simple fact is that we have
an obligation to have both of these
kinds of caring we have to have the love
we have to be loved we have to love to
know that we can be loved but we also
have to have the kind of caring that
recognizes that people we don't know
love people we don't know we have to
have that compassion it's a logical
realistic brain based world saving kind
of caring it's not gonna light a fire in
the pit of your stomach like your sick
cat but it is so powerful nonetheless to
understand that everything that we do
all the good and all the bad things
radiates through the world that we are
all connected to each other that we
aren't just connected to the other
people or can I get to the whole freakin
planet we're going to the whole freakin
planet and we have an obligation to
think about that we don't have an
obligation to feel every tree being cut
down like our cat just died we have to
have both we have to have the love we
have to have the compassion there is
overlap but you shouldn't get them
confused and Joan I just want you to
feel the way that I feel just because we
recognize that there are things wrong
with the world doesn't mean that we have
to feel the crushing weight of the world
pounding down upon us we just have to
recognize the world is screwed up and
that there are fun and cool ways to help
fix it and one fun and cool way to help
fix all those things I think yes
obviously is to cast your vote Chewbacca
Solo in 2012 Jon you'll see me tomorrow